marvel's wand division has finally
wrapped up the first big chapter of the
mcu's phase four
the grand finale left us with lots of
answers several new questions a killer
costume change and a few great fights
let's break down the small details you
may have missed and all the madness
one division hasn't exactly been an
action spectacle but its finale starts
off with a bang
on the suburban streets of westfield
with agatha holding billy and tommy
hostage the episode's opening sequence
sees agatha and wanda clash
while it won't be until later in the
episode that wanda shows what she can
really do
early in her battle with the older witch
wanda uses a trick she likely learned
from fighting iron man in captain
america's civil war
rather than using her powers on agatha
directly she taps into her telekinesis
to slam a car right into agatha when
wanda approaches the house to see what's
happened to her opponent she sees
agatha's boots sticking out from beneath
the car
as she inches closer she sees the boots
are empty the moment references 1939's
the wizard of oz
which includes the famous visual of a
house landing on top of the wicked witch
of the east
of course sun like the witch in the
earlier classic agatha isn't dead or
defeated
that's not the only reference to a
non-mcu movie in the episode either
as wanda vision billy and tommy face off
against the military in the town square
it's a shot very reminiscent to the
moment in the incredibles when the
family faces off against syndrome's
minions
there were a lot of rumors out there
indicating that benedict cumberbatch
might make a cameo in the one division
finale is dr
strange well the finale came and went
without any sign
from the resident of 177 ape leaker
street but that doesn't mean he was
forgotten entirely
as the battle between wanda and agatha
moves to the westview town center agatha
confirms what many of us have suspected
since the end of episode 7.
the tome she was keeping in her basement
is the infamous darkhold
ignoring wanda's protests agatha reads
from the book saying that the scarlet
witch is not
born she is forged she has no coven nor
need for incantation
perhaps the most impressive thing agatha
reads is that your power exceeds that of
the sorcerer supreme
as we know dr strange is the sorcerer
supreme and he's not exactly a street
magician
the argument could be made that of all
the heroes to go one-on-one with thanos
in avengers infinity war none make as
good as showing as doctor strange
of course wanda gives as good as she
gets when she shows up to settle her
score with the villain in endgame but
still
saying wanda is more powerful than
strange is significant
of the many things wanda does in her
battle against agatha she tries
something we haven't seen in quite a
while
appearing behind agatha she taps into
agatha's mind to uproot her nightmares
things don't go quite as planned while
wanda does unearth the vision of
agatha's old coven trying to kill her
the more experienced witch manages to
turn the tables on her
you can't blame wanda for trying since
this is a move that worked out well for
her in avengers age of ultron when we
see wanda use this power successfully on
almost all the avengers
we get to see wanda in a comic book
accurate get up in episode 6
but just as is often the case in the mcu
that costume was intentionally made to
look pretty goofy
similarly the costumes worn by vision
and the fake pietro don't come off like
what you'd expect to see the avengers
wearing while defending earth
but while we get hints of it in the
penultimate episode we don't get to see
wanda in her new and improved comics
accurate outfit until the series finale
and it's worth the wait we first see an
energy outline of the headpiece forming
while wanda is in agatha's nightmare
vision
after wanda places the runes of power
along her hex boundary and she accepts
who she is we finally get to see her
transformation begin
once she reclaims her power from agatha
she descends from the sky above westview
in an outfit that reflects her comic
book attire
and doesn't look like it was thrown
together at the last minute for her
costume party
in his final moments with wanda vision
offers words of comfort and hope
speculating that perhaps in spite of
everything this won't be the last time
they see one another
vision says to wanda i have been a voice
with no body
a body but not human and now a memory
made real
when he calls himself a voice with no
body vision is referring to his time
spent as jarvis
tony stark's ai assistant while he
doesn't appear in person in the mcu
until avengers age of ultron betany
voiced jarvis in the first two iron man
films and the first two avengers films
congratulations
you have created a new element unlike
his comic book counterparts whose brain
waves are based on those of the
superhero wonderman
vision's personality is something of a
fusion of different characters including
jarvis
that jarvis helps to create vision isn't
exactly an obscure fact
but considering how much the character
has been through since then it can be
very easy to forget that in a sense
vision has been with the mcu narrative
since the very
beginning by the end of wandavision
we're still not completely clear on what
monica rambo's repeated exposure to
wanda's hex has done to her
after she pierces the hex boundary a
second time in episode 7
it's clear that she's more than she used
to be what isn't clear is what that
means exactly
in episode 7 we see her eyes glow blue a
number of times and she recovers from an
assault by wanda quicker than you would
expect
but in the series finale we get a clue
that her abilities could be close to
those of her comic book counterpart
in the comics monica rambo has the
ability to transform herself into any
form of energy
particularly back in the 80s when she
first showed up rambo would often appear
covered in a golden hue as she
transformed into light itself
along with allowing her to travel
impossibly fast while she was in this
form
solid objects would pass through her
without harming her we see something
like that power in wand division when
hayward tries to shoot billy and tommy
monica steps between the director and
the boys and her eyes glow gold
as the bullets reach her they pass
through her harmlessly at the same time
the bullets are slowed down and monica's
entire body takes on a semi-transparent
golden appearance
back in episode 4 jimmy wu lists the
scrolls as one of the possible culprits
behind the westview hex
it turns out of course they have nothing
to do with it but that doesn't mean they
were going to completely keep their
noses out of what was going on
in the series finale's mid-credit scene
the authorities are wrapping things up
in westview when a woman leads monica
into a theater under false pretenses
the woman ultimately reveals herself to
be a scroll and tells monica
i was sent by an old friend of your
mother's she tells monica her old friend
wants to meet with her
when monica asks where the scroll points
meaningfully upward
in most likelihood the friend the skrull
is referring to is talos
the skrull who works with monica's
mother maria carol danvers and nick fury
and captain marvel
and who subsequently has a mid-credits
cameo in spider-man far from home
it could also be fury himself whoever
this old friend is will likely find out
in the upcoming captain marvel 2.
if you stick around for not just the
mid-credits scene but the post-credits
scene as well
then you see wanda in a cabin in some
distant wilderness looking pretty
similar to bruce banner's hideout at the
end of 2008's incredible hulk
guarding the cabin is an illusion of a
normal wanda while inside the building
we see the scarlet witch's astral form
accessing her powers and pouring over
the darkhold presumably to take agatha's
advice and learn more about who she is
and what she's capable of
just before the scene ends we hear billy
and tommy's voices calling out to wanda
for help
this is pretty significant because in
the comics while wanda's twins are
revealed to be constructs of her power
they are reincarnated in the forms of
the boys who become the heroes wiccan
and speed
while it's too soon to tell it seems
likely this could be exactly what leeds
wanted to join forces with the sorcerer
supreme and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
wanovision's eighth episode did a lot to
explain the mystery at the heart of the
mcu series
namely why did wanda make herself the
center of a strange surreal sitcom
let's dig even deeper into some of the
easter eggs and references in wanda's
real-life tv land
in episode 8 of wanda vision wanda is
made to see the night that her life was
ripped apart in sokovia
moments before a fateful explosion she
and her family are watching her favorite
episode
of the dick van dyke show season two's
it may look like a walnut
this is a classic episode of the series
as rob petry watches a science fiction
film about walnut obsessed aliens
infiltrating earth the next day
all the events of the film seem to come
true first his wife turns into a space
invader and then rob himself begins to
morph into an alien
the episode was a parody of the sci-fi
classic invasion of the body snatchers
only with the movie star danny thomas as
the extraterrestrial ringleader
the easter egg at play is that this dick
van dyke episode is really just a bad
dream
rob's wife hasn't been taken by the
aliens he's not missing his thumbs or
lost his sense of humor
similarly wanda takes all of the bad
things that have ever happened to her
and turned him into a bad dream
thanks to agatha harkness wanda
experiences a vivid flashback of her
childhood in episode viii
and for the first time we see the
incident that radicalized wanda and
pietro and drove them toward joining
hydra
in the middle of tv night the missile
rips through their house killing their
parents
pietro grabs wanda and pulls her under
the bed keeping her safe
but that's when another missile lands
three feet in front of them but it
doesn't go off
the siblings stay trapped under the bed
for two days before they move
and as the duo mentioned in avengers age
of ultron the rocket has a very familiar
word painted on the side
on the side of the shell let's paint it
one word
it's dark that spurs their hatred of
tony stark pushing them into the arms of
hydra as they volunteer for the
experiments that would give them their
powers up until this episode however
we'd only heard of this tragic event but
the scene in one division goes into
greater detail
including a reveal that the shell
actually said stark industries
more importantly i get the questions
wanda as to whether she ever wondered if
it was a coincidence that the bomb
didn't go
off did you stop that bomb what
you used a probability hex from her
perspective it's obvious that wando was
a baby witch who subconsciously used a
probability altering spell to prevent
the explosive from going off
during one of episode 8's flashback
sequences we see the mind stone float
out towards wanda
as a result she sees an image of a woman
in silhouette with flowing hair and a
headband very similar to the classic
scarlet witch costume
none of this is recorded by hydra's
cameras what exactly this is referring
to is unclear
is the mind stone seeing wanda's future
where she fully embraces her identity as
the scarlet witch
or is it a reference to her heritage in
the comics wanda learned only relatively
recently that her mother was actually a
natalya maximoff one in a long line of
scarlet witches
whatever the case may be this is the
point that wanda first comes into her
powers
however it's also clear from the start
that she's never had a good grip on how
she's able to do what she does
ascribing all of it to the mind stone's
influence it may well be that the mind
stone simply unlocked her own innate
abilities
after touching the mind stone wanda sits
down to watch an episode of the brady
bunch
in this particular installment cindy
brady is having an argument with her
brother bobby about her beloved doll
as for the plot of that particular brady
bunch episode the doll goes missing and
cindy blames bobby
the young boy professes his innocence
and their argument spills over into the
rest of the family before the real
culprits their dog is revealed that
episode is a subtle reminder that things
aren't always as they seem and we can
often overlook the real culprits and
create undeserved blame if we're not
careful
in other words wanda is being blamed for
certain things that she hasn't done
and agatha is gleefully stringing her
along the episode also has a slightly
more obvious connection to wandavision
the doll that the vision uses to
practice changing diapers on in episode
3 is an exact duplicate to that doll
in episode 8 wanda has a flashback to
the moment she visited sword
headquarters
in this heartbreaking scene she's led to
the vision's body and allowed to examine
it
i can't feel you wanda's line is a
callback to the vision's last words to
her in avengers infinity war
after agreeing to destroy vision to keep
his infinity stone away from thanos
vision tells her
you could never hurt me i just feel you
wanda revisiting that line in sword hq
is a sad acknowledgement to the end of
their connection
in episode 8's post-credits scene sword
director tyler hayward reveals that his
team has had a breakthrough
they've powered up the dead vision's
body using energy channeled from an
object directly affected by wanda's
magic
as it turns out all hayward has wanted
all along as a way to revive and control
the sentient weapon
this revived vision is a ghostly white a
direct reference to a period in the
comics when vision was torn apart and
then put back together by henry pym
during the late 80s
in the comics the ghostly barefoot
vision was drained of all emotions for
years
which led to more than a few super
villain plots will the same hold true
for vision 2.0 or will it all tie up in
a happy ending like the plots on wanda's
favorite tv shows
a silly mission that always becomes fine
one division seventh episode breaking
the fourth wall brings us to the late
aughts early 2000s in terms of sitcom
references
wanda vision agnes and even darcy
participate in talking head segments in
which they speak directly to the
audience
mirroring the mockumentary stylings of
sitcoms like modern family the office
and parks and recreation
while the style used in episode 7 feels
most like modern family this isn't where
the intro comes from
with its flashes of things you'd expect
to find in a workplace like computer
screens calendars and the i love wanda
coffee mug
plus the derivative theme music it feels
a lot more like the intro to the office
speaking of office comedies just before
the theme starts wanda tries to laugh
off the bizarre things happening in her
home with it's probably just a case of
the mondays
that's not a reference to the office but
rather a reference to the 1999 comedy
office space
uh oh sounds like somebody's got a case
of the mundus
the opening few minutes of episode seven
also hide one more easter egg
as wanda themed objects appear one by
one a license plate with wanda has the
numbers 12
28 22 those numbers are a reference to
stan lee's birth date of december 28
1922
although the late comic book icon won't
be making any more cameos in future mcu
projects the subtle shout out makes it
clear that lee is gone but definitely
not forgotten
breaking the fourth wall doesn't show
the brothers in their costumes but the
color scheme of their clothing does
reflect those of their comic book
costumes
the green and white of tommy's outfit
look a lot more like what he wears as
the young superhero speed
when wanda gets her breakfast she's
understandably freaked out about her
milk's container transforming a few
times
at one point it becomes a carton with a
picture of a missing child on the back
though we can't make out the child's
face putting the pictures of missing
children on milk cartons became
customary in the mid-80s so it's
interesting to remember that the one
division episode dealing with the 80s
episode 5 on a very special episode
also happens to be the same episode in
which vision points out that westview's
children are missing
wanda's cereal is interesting as well
first the brand's mascot is a cartoon
clown
and at the end of the previous episode
wanda's expanding hex radius changes the
sword agents into circus clowns
second there's the name sugar snaps it's
impossible to see or hear the word snap
in an mcu production without thinking of
the most infamous snap of all
the one thanos makes to kill half the
universe
as a result of wanda's swiftly expanding
hex radius at the end of episode 6
unlike most of the sword agents who are
turned into clowns agent monty is
changed into the circus strongman
it's unlikely that monty has been made
into any kind of superhero but at the
same time when we see a guy in a comic
book tv show and a colorful tight outfit
with a big s on his belt there's a good
chance that means something when you
combine the s with the blue and yellow
color scheme there are a couple of
different superheroes this could be
referencing and both of them are super
strong
one possibility is the mutant hero
strong guy when he first joins the new
version of x-factor a strong guy like
the rest of the team wears a blue and
yellow uniform
another possibility and a more fitting
one is the sentry like monty's get up
century's original outfit is yellow and
blue and it includes an
s on the belt also while he isn't
introduced until 2000 the century number
one
it's revealed the hero has been around
since the early days of marvel but the
entire world has forgotten about it
including the sentry himself just as
monty has forgotten who he is
understandably because of reports that
elizabeth olsen's wanda maximoff will be
an important part of the upcoming doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
fans have been theorizing that
wandavision would have something to do
with marvel's vast multiverse
one of the most overt signs we receive
in the story itself is the commercial in
episode vii
while the same man and woman who
regularly appear in one division's faux
commercials weren't around in episode
six
they return in breaking the fourth wall
for an ad that mimics antidepressant
commercials
the brand name of the medication is
nexus a word that has two meanings in
marvel comics
both of which relate to the multiverse
there is marvel's nexus of all realities
which in the prime universe of the
comics exists in the florida everglades
and is guarded by the monstrous man
thing
as the name implies the nexus is a
gateway to marvel's other realities
and then there's wanda herself in the
comics wanda is the nexus being of the
prime marvel reality as a nexus being
wanda reflects her reality's defining
characteristics and can alter the flow
of the future
in the 1998-99 mini-series avengers
forever we learn the powerful immortus
knows wanda is a nexus being
and fears the possibility of her having
children even more powerful than herself
he manipulates events to pair vision and
wanda off as a couple in the futile hope
that wanda's coupling with an android
could never produce offspring
in episode 4 of wandavision we hear
echoes from 2019's captain marvel as
monica is resurrected during the blip we
hear those voices and more again in
episode 7 as monica forces her way
through the hex barrier
and this time it seems clear monica is
hearing them as well we hear the young
monica talking with her late mother
about helping carol danvers we hear nick
fury tell her that she can only follow
the adult heroes as she can learn to
glow like her aunt carol
and we know in the comments she does
glow we also hear different people like
dr harley and jimmy wu
speaking about the death of monica's
mother and of course we hear a refrain
of this line
your mom's lucky when they were handing
out kids they gave her the toughest one
lieutenant trouble he remembered
it's those words that give monica the
strength to push the rest of the way
through the barrier
piercing the hex barrier gives monica
superpowers though it isn't clear
exactly what those powers mean we see
her eyes glow blue
several times and she recovers so
quickly from wanda's assault toward the
end of episode 7 that even
wanda is shocked in the comics monica is
quietly one of the most powerful heroes
in marvel
she's had a number of aliases the most
recent being spectrum and after she's
bombarded with energy from another
dimension she gains the ability to
transform into any form of energy at
will
she's also had another alias that's been
hinted on screen before
photon just like monica's mother's call
sign in the mcu
by the end of breaking the fourth wall a
lot of fans suspicions that agnes might
be more than a friendly neighbor seem to
have been confirmed
wanda's own suspicions are sparked when
agnes leads her into her home and wanda
notices the twins are nowhere to be seen
she then sees a large loud insect on the
window shade
she asks agnes where the boys are and
agnes answers that they're probably just
playing in the basement
wanda goes down to the basement to look
for them and we get the episode's
biggest reveal
this all unfolds like a tribute to the
silence of the lambs
toward the end of that film the hero
clarice starling believes she's just
doing a routine interview about the
first victim of notorious serial killer
buffalo bill
she's speaking to a man who now lives
where the person she wants to interview
used to live
she's already suspicious of his manner
and some of the things she sees in his
house
but when she notices a large exotic moth
something the killer leaves behind in
his victims throats that seals the deal
she pulls her gun on him and he runs to
the basement where they have their final
showdown
when wanda and agnes confront each other
in agnes basement we learn
agnes isn't agnes she's the witch agatha
harkness
we then get a montage of moments
throughout the series when it's revealed
agatha was manipulating events
it isn't clear however exactly what
agatha is after
harkness isn't a villain in the comics
in fact at different times harkness has
been wanda's ally and even a mentor
while not really a superhero in the
traditional sense she has surfaced every
now and then to aid superheroes during
different mystical crises
so while it's finally confirmed that
agnes is agatha we still don't know why
she's there
it also isn't clear just what she means
when she says it was her
all along just before agatha reveals
herself in the basement wanda notices
what appears to be a very serious
looking tone
shimmering with crimson energy we're not
exactly sure what this
is though it could be the darkhold the
darkhold is probably the most infamous
magic tome in the history of marvel
comics
sought after by the likes of doctor
strange and even the vampire king count
dracula himself
the thing is we've already seen the dark
hole in the mcu in both agents of shield
and runaways
and it didn't look like this but on the
other hand it isn't completely clear
exactly what canonical weight a lot of
the marvel tv series have in the mcu
whatever it is when we see agatha use
magic it's accompanied by purple energy
the energy coming out of the book on the
other hand is more red like wanda's
also the design of the book's cover
features two sets of adjoined rings
kind of like twins and wanda's boys are
nowhere to be seen
whatever the book is whether it's the
dark gold or something else
it could be acting as the twins prison
don't change that channel wandavision is
continuing to reinvent the wheel for the
marvel cinematic universe
taking the reality warping series into a
1990s pastiche
won division 6 episode all new halloween
spooktacular takes a leap over the 90s
to deposit us in the early aughts
with its faux home video camera work and
pop punk theme the intro to episode 6
echoes the intro to the sitcom malcolm
in the middle
which premiered in early 2000 and
concluded in 2006.
the intro song includes lyrics
reflecting the bizarre events in west
view like don't try to fight the chaos
and
later what if it's all an illusion
amusingly the actual theme song to
malcolm in the middle with its you're
not the boss of me now refrain also
feels like it would be suitable for
wanda's reality warping rebellion
like malcolm often did with its title
character episode 6 begins with billy
narrating though his inner dialogue
doesn't last past the first scene
young avengers fans are no doubt hoping
that billy and his brother tommy will
eventually grow to become their super
powered comic book counterparts
in the comics billy is wiccan a mystical
hero and one of the founding members of
the young avengers
meanwhile tommy is like quicksilver a
mutant with the gift of super speed
whose code name is creatively speed
whether or not billy and tommy appear in
the mcu after wand division bands can at
least say they got a chance to see them
use their powers and dress in there
for the most part comic book accurate
costumes billy's costume which he wears
throughout the episode is wicken's
costume in the comics pietro gives tommy
a smaller version of his own costume
which is not what speed wears in the
comics but it's still fitting
considering his powers
you may also notice that just before
pietro starts wreaking havoc in the
suburban neighborhood with his nephews
he and tommy share a top gun reference
episode 6 gives us some scenes between
pietro and wanda after the bombshell
cameo at the end of episode 5.
and unsurprisingly there are a lot of
obvious callbacks to 2015's avengers age
of ultron
sokovia is mentioned a few times
including wanda saying her outfit is a
sokovian fortune teller and a quick
flashback to the young wanda and pietro
trick-or-treating in their homeland
wanda mentions their childhood growing
up in an orphanage together and after
she calls pietro a bad influence the
brother fires back who beefed in your
borscht
with borscht being from the same region
of europe where you would find zakovia
if it were a real place right after that
exchange the twins both ask each other
about the disappearances of their
accents
something wanda slips back into briefly
in the previous episode
and of course there are the references
to pietro's death early in the episode
tommy teases billy
saying that his twin is afraid that
pietro is a vampire a creature who
possibly like pietro is neither dead nor
alive
you get killed walk it off
at the town square scare peter tells his
sister he remembers being shot like a
chump
and later she has a brief vision of him
pale and riddled with bullet holes
you didn't see that coming
one thing worth noting is that pietro
says he was shot like a chump for no
reason at all
when in fact in age of ultron he
sacrifices himself in order to save
hawkeye and sokovian boy
which seems like a pretty worthy cause
to us all new halloween spooktacular
finally gives us wanda and vision in
their old school marvel comic book
getups
images of the pair in their half-baked
costumes were some of the first photos
released for the series
billy appropriately thinks his mother is
dressed as old red riding hood while
pietro compares vision to a traffic
light a half shucked corn cob and a
booger
and he's what you call a man-child after
pietro suggests he joined wanda and the
boys for halloween wanda says he doesn't
have a costume
prompting piedro to use his super speed
to put himself in tommy in matching
outfits reflecting what quicksilver used
to wear in marvel's comics
the silver lightning bolt is straight
from the funny books as is the slicked
back wolverine style hair
does it look good in real life well not
really but it's still a pretty neat
thing to finally see
some fans are understandably hopeful
that evan peters's presence in
wandavision could be the beginning of
the entrance of the x-men into the mcu
while it's far too soon to say whether
this is the case episode 6 has a couple
of x-men references early in the story
as a couple argue about whether or not
vision will be trick-or-treating with
wanda and the boys pietro steps in to
take the synthesoid's place
big guy is a conflict twins need a
father figure for the night
don't sweat it sis i got the old xy
chromosome
weird line right for ph or to mention
his dna and the letter
x is a pretty obvious reference to the
team professor x built
there's another x-men reference that's
just a bit easier to miss a few moments
earlier
the neighborhood watch is the only thing
that stands between the trees and the
toilet paper
as vision says his line he points in
opposite directions and his forearms
cross to form a big yellow
x the ad for all new halloween
spooktacular is perhaps the most bizarre
faux commercial we've seen yet on
wandavision the ad uses stop motion
animation and shows us a boy stuck on an
island in the middle of the ocean
a talking shark drops in with a
surfboard gives a boy a yo magic yogurt
snack and leaves
the boy can't seem to open the container
and his teeth clatter as if he's
freezing even though the sun seems to be
baking him
time speeds up and he keeps trying and
failing to open the yo magic snack
eventually he withers away to a skeleton
the ad ends with a shot of the yomagic
packaging and the slogan yo magic the
snack for survivors
the ad seems to be a fusion of at least
a couple of different brands of similar
snacks from the 90s and early aughts
the packaging is reminiscent of
yoplait's gogurt while the ad itself
pulls heavily from yoga yogurt which use
stop motion in its ads
as for magic being essential for
survival a message seems obvious
at the town square scare a movie marquee
gives us a couple more easter eggs
and like many of the other references
there's a bit of a time gap between them
westview's coronet theater is showing
two films on screen one is the
incredibles which came out in 2004.
it's a fitting movie reference
considering by the end of episode 6
every member of wanda and vision's
family has superpowers
in fact only moments after we see the
marquee tommy discovers his super speed
screen 2 is showing the parent trap
however which assuming we're talking
about the remake and not the original
from 1961
came out six years before the
incredibles in 1998.
either way both versions of the film
feature a pair of twins separated at
birth
it's an apt reference considering how
pietro and wanda have been separated
since a former's death and how
in the comics at least billy and tommy
were long-lost twins themselves
each week wandavision reveals new and
more interesting layers to its strange
tv inspired reality
episode 5 is certainly no exception with
plenty of hidden pop culture and mcu
references
when we return to wandavision's strange
sitcom reality and on a very special
episode
wanda vision and all the residents of
west view have moved into the prime time
programming of the 80s
in particular the intro borrows from
family ties among other things family
ties is known for making the young
michael j
fox famous even before he became a time
traveler in 1985's back to the future
the most blatant pull from the series is
the initially colorless portrait that
begins to be colored in by a paintbrush
controlled by wanda
family ties intro for its first three
seasons included a similar portrait
it's a nifty visual allusion to the way
wanda colored in the gray and lifeless
vision that viewers briefly spotted at
the end of wandavision's fourth episode
on a very special episode has its share
of 80s references but they don't all
stay in the 80s
when agnes visits wanda and vision she
tells them she stopped by on her way to
jazzercise
founded in the late 60s and still around
today jazzercise hit its peak in the mid
80s
we get another purely 80s reference
toward the end of the episode
in the kitchen wanda tells vision well
life moves pretty fast out in the
suburbs
it sounds a lot like matthew broderick's
famous quote from 1986's ferris
bueller's day off
life moves pretty fast you don't stop
and look around once in a while
you could miss it but some of these
references don't really find homes in
the 80s
early in the episode agnes yells fussy
babies meet buns of steel
the buns of steel workout videos while
technically originating in the late 80s
didn't really become a craze until the
early 90s
we get a similar moment when norm
references a catchphrase that hit its
peak in the late 80s and 90s
what do you think norm should we surf
the internet cowabunga dude
cowabunga dude is most associated with
the teenage mutant ninja turtles and to
a lesser
extent off-brand simpsons merchandise
i have always liked
huh
these blurrings between 80s and 90s pop
culture could be intentional
it could be a sign that just as vision
is becoming more aware of wanda's
illusions the integrity of her dream
world is deteriorating
in the 2016 vision comic series vision
lives in the suburbs with a synthazoid
wife
son and daughter they also eventually
have a synthasoid dog named sparky
not only is wondervision sparky a
callback to the comic series but is
close call with the kitchen's power
outlet is as well
like the sparky of wandavision the
sparky of the comics initially meets a
sad though much more brutal end
however he's eventually brought back to
the land of the living ironically
considering wanda's decision not to
revive the pooch and on a very special
episode
scarlet witch is one of the heroes who
could bring the flying pooch back to
life
and on a very special episode
wandavision's strange advertisers are
back
this time the ad is for lagos a paper
towel brand showing lagos wiping up an
identical spill to what the leading
brand is trying and failing to clean
the add mirrors bounty commercials of
the 80s that touted their paper towels
the quicker picker-upper
the name lagos is a blatant reference to
captain america's civil war
it's wanda who unintentionally incites
the film's conflict when she
accidentally kills wakandan volunteers
in the nigerian city of lagos rather
than calling lagos a quicker
picker-upper the ad
ends with the slogan lagos for when you
make a mess
you didn't mean to fittingly the juice
that the towels clean up resembles blood
one thing that's easy to miss about the
ad is the reference to what's going on
with vision
just before the end of the commercial
the husband knocks over a glass of beer
the wife hands him a few towels as the
narrator says husbands can use it too
you know
this could reflect not only how vision
begins to assert himself but how episode
5 shows he has a degree
of control over the illusions for
example he's able to temporarily free
norm from wanda's telepathy
this may also be why agnes is so
flustered early in the episode when she
isn't sure whether she's supposed to
hold the babies
because she's getting conflicting
signals from vision and wanda
and then of course there's the reveal at
the end of on a very special episode
that will doubtless go down as one of
the biggest tv moments of 2021.
the doorbell rings as wanda and vision
argue and after wanda answers the door
we're greeted by a familiar face but
familiar in a way that we don't expect
before we see the visitor's face we see
the back of his head which sports a head
of hair that looks a lot like the one
belonging to pietro maximoff
wanda's brother who dies heroically in
avengers age of ultron
we are indeed greeted by wanda's brother
but a different pietro than the one most
viewers had to have been expecting
instead of aaron taylor johnson who
plays pietro in the mcu film
wanda finds herself facing evan peters
who plays peter maximoff in 2014's x-men
days of future past as well as the final
two films of fox's x-men franchise
as darcy points out as she notices the
change pietro maximoff has been recast
alluding to the fact that american
sitcoms are famous for their sometimes
abrupt recasting of characters
one of the most well remembered examples
of this comes from a sitcom one division
mirrors in its second episode
bewitched the main character's husband
darren was recast when dick york was
replaced by dick sargent in the series
sixth
four episodes end and wanda vision keeps
revealing new and more interesting
layers to this strange new reality
we interrupt this program opens with the
first extended on-screen depiction of
the blip the resurrection of all the
people killed by thanos snap in avengers
infinity war spider-man far from home
lets us know how the event comes to be
known as the blip and some of the
consequences of it but this is the first
time we get a good long look at the
chaos immediately following the event
specifically we see monica rambo
returning from the dead in a hospital
room where her mother was a patient
during the events of infinity war
as rambo's body reforms we hear dialogue
from 2019's captain marvel
your mom's lucky when they were handing
out kids they gave her the toughest one
lieutenant trouble you remember
it's a fitting way to start the episode
considering one of the biggest mysteries
the story presents is how the
synthesized vision has returned from the
dead
considering all the hints that have been
dropped in the previous three episodes
it's no surprise to learn that monica
rambo works for sword
her scenes with director hayward pretty
strongly imply that she was the
front-runner for his job before thanos's
snap made that impossible
but while she may not have the top
position monica isn't without rank and
sword
after monica's security badge doesn't
work at headquarters director hayward
shows up and introduces her to the
security guard as captain monica rambo
the rank isn't an accident when she
shows up in marvel comics monica is a
different kind of captain
after obtaining the ability to transform
into any form of energy
monica becomes known as captain marvel
years before carol danvers takes up the
title
in the opening scene of the episode we
learned that maria rambo
is dead from a conversation between
monica and dr hyland it's revealed that
at some point between the events
of captain marvel and those of infinity
war maria was diagnosed with cancer
when thanos made his fateful snap maria
had just undergone a procedure to treat
her cancer and it was deemed a success
because thanos's snap wiped monica from
existence she awakes not knowing that
her mother's cancer soon returned and
she died three years before the blip
but when monica returns to sword it's
clear her mother isn't forgotten
as director hayward leads monica into
the headquarters they pass by a number
of portraits
including one of maria rambo with her
callsign photon
maria wasn't just a high-ranking member
of sword either
hayward says she built this place from
the ground up which makes sense
after all sword in the comics deals with
extraterrestrial threats
and as far as we know maria is one of
the first few mcu earthlings to
knowingly have contact with any
extraterrestrials
we first meet fbi agent wu in 2019's
ant-man and the wasp when wu was in
charge of babysitting scott lang while
lang's under house arrest were violating
the sokovia accords and captain america
civil
war in one division he's the fbi agent
waiting for monica rambo to help him
with his missing persons case
and their introduction to one another
includes an easter egg from his very
first mcu scene
in ant-man and the wasp scott uses
sleight of hand to make a playing card
appear out of thin air
later wu has an important question for
scott how'd you do it scott
do what the card trick
seriously it turns out we was a huge fan
of sleight of hand
and wandavision reveals that he's been
honing his skills since babysitting
scott
as he's approaching monica for the first
time he uses the same trick to produce
his business card
during the montage that shows us the
progress of the joint task force
investigation we get a couple of shots
of agent wu taking notes on a dry erase
board
under the heading what is behind this wu
is written extraterrestrials
scrolls we first meet the shape-shifting
scrolls in captain marvel
and what we know about them so far makes
wu's notion very interesting
while scrolls are traditionally villains
in the comics captain marvel shows that
they're just trying to survive being
annihilated by the cree in the mcu
captain marvel and her allies help the
aliens and in the mid credits scene of
spider-man far from home they appear to
be working with nick fury
so why would agent wu or anyone else
suspect them of something nefarious
it could be that relations between earth
and the scrolls have changed
another possibility is that while
captain marvel seemed to imply its
scrolls were some of the last the cree
hadn't wiped out
maybe there are more of the
shapeshifters out there who aren't as
friendly as the ones working with nick
fury
the conclusion of we interrupt this
program implies that wanda is behind all
the weirdness going on in wandavision
at least that's monica's theory when
wanda uses her power to hurl monica
beyond the boundaries of west view and
she lands among the joint task force
monica has one conclusion
[Music]
it's all wonder
the episode ends with wanda and vision
sitting down with their newborn twins to
watch some tv
as the jimi hendrix experiences 1968
voodoo child slight return plays
the song is a perfect cap to reinterrupt
this program for a couple of reasons
while the word voodoo can refer to any
number of things an american pop culture
is often associated with witchcraft
making the song just one of a growing
list of things referencing witchcraft in
the series
more importantly there are the opening
lyrics hendrix sings
well i stand up next to a mountain and i
chop it down with the edge of my hand
then later in the verse we hear well i
pick up all pieces and make an island
might even raise a little sand if monica
is right and wanda is behind everything
going on in west view then the imagery
of someone chopping down mountains and
using the debris to build an island is
pretty fitting for the series
wandavision is the mcu's weirdest
project to date full of very obvious
sitcom references and more than a few
subtle hints that something in wanda's
world is very
very wrong the third episode is no
different prior to the release of wand
division the last time we saw scarlet
witch she was tearing thanos apart
single-handedly posing for a group shot
and chatting with clint barton after
tony stark's funeral
that's where he left her an end game but
in this show her main challenge seems to
be in the realm of new beginnings
while working on her nursery wanda
unintentionally makes the butterflies of
the mobile above the crib
turn into actual butterflies this is a
reference to a popular marvel comics
miniseries and could even be the
foreshadowing for a character who is yet
to be revealed
kicking already wow oh it's such a
strange sensation it's kind of fluttery
one of the comic book series fans have
been comparing most of wand division is
2005's mini-series house of amp
in fact paul bettany has said
wandavision was pitched to him
specifically as a mashup of the comic
book's vision and house of m
in the latter series wanda uses her
reality warping powers to completely
remake the world with a few noteworthy
exceptions here and there most of the
people in this new reality have no idea
the world's been remade but one of the
few exceptions is leila miller who comes
to be known as
you guessed it butterfly layla is a
mutant before house of m
and somehow wanda's reality warping
gives her the ability to awaken people
into the knowledge that they're living
in a world gone wrong
nor do we think that this is the last
time layla is referenced in episode
three
when they're talking about what to name
who they assume will be their newborn
son
wanda jokes about hoping it's a girl
later when vision practices changing a
diaper he uses a girl doll with blonde
hair
just like leila in spite of the fact
that he and wanda seem to be sure their
child will be a void
the episode also keeps up the trend by
breaking up the action with a surreal
fake commercial
episode three's advertisement pulls from
old commercials for calgon a water
softening brand with a line of bath and
beauty products
in the 70s and 80s there was a popular
series of advertisements in which
overworked overstressed women would
throw their hands up and beg for
deliverance from the calgon brand
that does it
after uttering the magic phrase it would
be transported to a bathtub where they
would be overcome with comfort
in this ad a busy mother can't even eat
her breakfast without her kids knocking
her cereal away with a soccer ball a dog
reminiscent division's pet sparky from
the vision comic
minus the green fur pees against the
wall then a narrator asks her do you
need a break you read my mind
which is of course something that wanda
can literally do the woman in the
commercial is transported to a bubble
bath where a man in a roman toga fans
are like a doting servant
among other things a narrator says when
you want to get away but you don't want
to go anywhere
which could be a description of what's
happening to wanda and vision
he also speaks of a place where your
problems float away which evokes the way
in which wanda makes things float away
with her mind
the mom likewise blows bubbles off her
hands as if she has similar powers
finally the product is revealed hydra
soaked the slogan is find the goddess
within
it's a clear reference to the powers
hydra gave wanda and the fact that those
powers are clearly expanding
it's also intriguing that the product
box reads made in usa
since that's not where hydro was formed
nor is it where wanda was when she was
given her powers
if you're familiar with the hit sitcom b
witch starring elizabeth montgomery as a
witch who both uses her powers to solve
her family's problems and struggles to
keep her identity as a witch secret
it's impossible not to think of the show
while watching wandavision it comes to
mind early in the premiere episode when
wanda is putting her dishes away with
her telekinetic powers but the
similarities get kicked up a notch in
the opening credits of episode 2. when
instead of using the dick van dyke show
for inspiration
wandavision uses animation reminiscent
of bewitched unique style
it's a particularly fitting show to
choose to pull from for episode 2 for a
few reasons
one of the most obvious is the fact that
both shows deal with witchcraft
another is that just as episode 2 ends
with the world of wanda vision changing
from black and white to color
bewitched began its life as a black and
white show in 1964 and changed to color
in 1966
early in episode 2 we get our first bit
of color mixed in with the black and
white and it's as striking as it is
meaningful
after practicing the magic act with
vision wanda is straightening up the
living room when she hears a worrying
and bang from outside
in the bushes of her front yard she
finds a toy helicopter unlike everything
else in this black and white world the
helicopter shows some color it's red and
gold with some metallic silver mixed in
the number 57 is on its side and the
sword symbol is painted on the front
the number on the helicopter isn't
randomly chosen the first comic book
appearance of the vision comes in 1968's
avengers number 57
and once again just as the toastmate
2000 reminds us of tony stark for some
reason or another the helicopter happens
to be painted in iron man's classic
colors
like the premiere wand division episode
the second episode treats us to another
faux advertisement
this time instead of a toaster we get a
watch manufactured by a company
called strucker and the commercial is
chalk full of easter eggs
first there's the most obvious reference
baron von strucker whose short mcu life
ends with avengers age of ultron
is in charge of the experiments which
give wanda and her late brother pietro
their powers
he's part of hydra whose sinister logo
is visible on the watch face
aligned as they are the watch hands
can't help but bear a resemblance to
loki's scepter
from which wanda and pietro's power
spring then there's the time
the watch is showing the time of 242 and
if you're looking for easter eggs in
marvel media pay attention to numbers
consequentially 1984's avengers number
242 is a pretty important one for the
team and for vision and scarlet witch in
particular
the pair are reunited when vision's body
is finally restored after injuries he
suffered during a previous adventure
early in episode two wanda and vision
practiced their magic act for the talent
show in the living room
and later we get to see that act
completely go off the rails when
swallowing a piece of chewing gum messes
with vision's inside so much that he
acts like a raving trunk
in both scenes we also see what vision
calls the cabinet of mysteries
equipped with a secret door to let its
occupant seem to have disappeared
adorning the cabinet is a picture of the
mind stone stuck division's head
it's not just an easter egg but a
meaningful reference his mind stone was
destroyed off camera by thanos and the
stone from the past was presumably
returned by captain america
the purpose of the cabinet as a device
to make things disappear and reappear
might also have some significance
after all both the mind stone and vision
are things that were supposed to
disappear but didn't
at least not completely when wanda and
dottie confront each other in the middle
of episode 2 the 1965 hit single helped
me rhonda by the beach boys is playing
on a nearby radio
it may seem like a song chosen just
because of the era until you think about
both the name of the song and some of
the lyrics
first of all there's the title rhonda
sounds a lot like wanda
then there's what the beach boys are
singing on the surface the song is about
a man devastated by his fiance cheating
on him
and asking rhonda to get her out of his
heart but if you think of it in the
context of vision and wanda's shared
history it becomes a much darker story
particularly with these lyrics she was
going to be my wife and i was going to
be her man but she let another guy come
between us and it shattered our plans
the last thing vision and wanda talk
about before being attacked by the black
order in avengers infinity war is making
their relationship more permanent
then another guy i.e thanos shatters not
only their plans but literally shatters
vision
as soon as preview images began popping
up for one division it became clear the
show was taking part of its inspiration
from a fan-favorite but short-lived
comic book series
in early 2016 marvel comics released the
first issue of tom king and gabriel
hernandez waltos vision
the synthezoid had enjoyed a couple of
mini-series before then but this one was
unique
this vision comic also found its title
character trying to build an idyllic and
ordinary life in a quiet suburb
rather than being married to scarlet
witch however vision builds his family
his synthesis his wife virginia his son
vin and his daughter viv
unlike the heroes of juan division the
synthazoid and his family make no
attempt to hide what they are in the
vision comic
which leads to more than a few
complications no spoilers but here's
hoping one division has a happier ending
the style of the first episode of
wandavision is based on sitcoms of the
50s and early 60s
and the photo intro includes a funny
easter egg calling back to one of those
classic programs
the dick van dyke show the reference
isn't so much about what happens though
as much as it is about what doesn't
happen
fans of the dick band dyke show will
likely notice the similarity in theme
music with wandavisions
they'll also remember that in some
episodes of the dick van dyke show the
intro includes the titular star tripping
over the ottoman in his living room and
taking a tumble there is also an
alternate version used occasionally
where dick sidesteps the ottoman
in wanda vision's intro vision almost
finds himself making the same mistake
as he's carrying wanda into their living
room unlike van dyke however vision's
powers allow him to face right through
the precariously placed furniture and
deliver wanda to the living room without
injury
laughing at people in pain is a
manifestation of a
deep-seated hostility
there's a lot of twin imagery in the
first two episodes of wandavision
usually in the form of matching sets of
jewelry furniture and other objects
and in some cases the matching pair is
missing for example when agnes
introduces herself to wanda she notices
wanda doesn't wear a wedding ring though
wanda takes care of this toward the end
of the episode
there's also the two lobsters that wanda
accidentally sends flying out of her
kitchen window that subsequently vision
can't find
there's the couple's twin beds and other
twin sets of furniture and even the
matching pieces of toast in the
toastmate 2000 commercial
both of wand division's first two
episodes include a fake advertisement
in episode 1 we get an ad for the
toastmate 2000.
among other things it gives us the first
indication that wandavision could be
taking place in the same world as the
rest of the mcu
as we find out the devices built by
stark industries
the all-new toastmate 2000 by stark
industries
the toastmate 2000 is also a clever
reference to both vision and wanda's
comic book twin sons
vision is after all wanda's mate and
like the toaster he's part machine
the toaster of course creates two
matching pieces of toasted bread just
like wanda and vision's matching twin
boys
and who makes the toast mate 2000 stark
industries
just like how it's tony stark who is one
of vision's creators in avengers age of
ultron
there are a lot of allusions to witches
and witchcraft and wandavision which is
fitting considering wanda's alter ego is
the scarlet witch
one such easter egg is part of the
format for the wanovision show within a
show
at the end of both of the first two wan
division episodes a couple is framed in
a hexagon as the end credits role that's
not something commonly seen in sitcoms
of any era
one explanation is that it's referencing
wanda's powers
while we've never heard them described
this way in the mcu movies or tv shows
and the comics wanda's ranged blasts are
called hexpears
not to mention that a hex commonly means
a spell or curse cast by a witch
when agnes takes it upon herself to help
wanda create a memorable romantic
evening in episode 1
she uses tips from a woman's magazine
called glamorous
now you could understandably assume
there's nothing much to make of that
title
until we get to episode 2. wanda and
vision volunteered to be part of the
talent show benefiting westview
elementary and they put on a magic
act vision plays the magician and wanda
plays his lovely assistant glamour
i am glamour and he's illusion
this is yet another reference to
witchcraft well usually when we talk
about glamour we're talking about
someone's attractiveness or their
lifestyle there is another meaning for
the work
a glamour can also mean a mystical
enchantment in particular it's typically
an illusion
for a perfect mcu example think of loki
when loki disguises himself as someone
else that would be called a glamour and
considering how much you come to
question the reality of what's going on
in one division that word carries some
weight
in the final moments of one division's
premiere episode we pull back from the
screen showing the sitcom to see a desk
the screenplay in the faux sitcom is
surrounded by much more contemporary
technology
and someone whose face we don't see is
sitting and watching the strange show
more importantly on the monitor to the
left of the tv screen and on a notepad
on the desk we see a symbol familiar to
marvel comics fans
the symbol with the blade as the picture
suggests belongs to an organization
called sword whose acronym in the comic
stands for sentient world observation
and response department
the agency is first revealed in joss
whedon and john cassaday's astonishing
x-men run when they're introduced as the
space counterpart to shield
while shield deals with earthbound
threats sword handles threats from the
stars
fans have been theorizing about the
mcu's sword for years and the symbols at
the end of episode 1 let us know they're
finally here
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one